we have to start though with what you
need to know and you today is you any
professional football player who may be
out there
considering whether to opt out of the
2020 season because today
is the deadline with a small asterisk
today is the day you must decide whether
you're going to opt out if you don't you
have very limited opportunities to do so
after today you either have to have a
diagnosis of some sort of a high risk
medical condition that you currently
don't have or you have to have a family
member who is hospitalized or who dies
from covet 19. if you
don't fit into either of those two
categories and hopefully you won't you
won't get a chance to opt out again if
you do opt out today by 4 pm eastern
it's irrevocable you're done for the
entire season you can't change your mind
later you can't pull a brett favre you
can't come back you are done for the
entire year your contract delays for one
full season and you just come back when
the next off season begins if there is
an offseason program next year
chris
i'm going to mention again
what i said yesterday
i'm going to
reiterate what i posted earlier today
for the guys who think they need more
time explore the retirement option is
something you can do later talk to your
agent before four o'clock eastern today
to know what it would cost you if
anything to retire later and unretire
later and remember there's a deadline
for unretiring it's late in the season
but you have that opportunity to walk
away for at least the rest of the season
if you want you can try to come back if
things get better but don't feel like
there's no way out don't feel like
you're trapped if you get to a point
where circumstances change and you're no
longer comfortable you don't have to
stay you can retire there's an easy path
if you wouldn't owe a significant amount
of money to the team yeah that's the
problem and even then even then even
then some guys may say i'll write the
check i don't care yeah i mean they
might you're right but that's that's the
one curveball i think in that approach
and and you're you're not wrong with
what you're saying it is a good piece of
advice for people to for players to
think like oh today's it or i'm done
forever and i gotta play football but uh
yeah it's it's gonna be that it's the
signing bonus aspect right mike i mean
you get a guy who gets you know retired
and
if he had a five million dollar signing
bonus and depending on what year he is
and his contract and everything like
that he might have to pay back a chunk
of that so that that is going to be yeah
something that you'll have to figure out
with your agent but we'll see i mean
i don't know what do you think like what
if you had a guest today as the day goes
on you think we're gonna see
three five guys here at the end of the
day go okay i just i've seen enough over
the last 11 days i don't trust it i'm
out of here or do you think we've
already seen the the majority of our
opt-outs and we're all done
no i think you're going to have some
guys
as long as possible yeah i mean i talked
to people from the union not that long
ago and they were hoping that guys would
wait as long as possible to get as much
information as they could before they
make that decision because if you choose
to opt out you can't change your mind so
there may be guys leaning toward opting
out but recognizing that once they go
there they can't come back let's wait
until
right before that 4 p.m eastern deadline
on thursday before putting pen to paper
and notifying the team in writing it has
to be a notification in writing by 4 pm
eastern today that you are opting out
one guy who is
considering it chris and if he opts out
he'll be the biggest name to opt out and
all pro last year at the cornerback
position from the buffalo bills todavius
white he's is still undecided he talked
about it yesterday here he is
honestly i'm still undecided man
i got until tomorrow but you know i i
just wanted to come in
and kind of see
like how it was going to go like how the
season was going to go as far as like
moving around in the locker room just
how how is the day-to-day operation and
uh just talking it over with my old lady
and just seeing what would be the best
decision for for my kids too and and
that playing a part in it and just
trying to see how
them being up here and not being being
able to come to the games and moving
around and my kids being able to go to
school and just being away from my
family for such a long time without
being able to do anything so we just
kind of just
taking it down to the last day and we're
going to decide from there so i'm still
kind of undecided
honestly smart move take it to the last
day if you're undecided because if you
opt out you can't un-opt out and look
this is a real factor chris tredavious
white a first-round pick in 2017 he's
got three years in which means he's
eligible for a second contract he's due
to make 1.8 million this year in salary
right next year under the fifth year
option 10.2 million now all of that will
get pushed back a year but here's the
thing and there's nothing wrong with
this even if you're simply using it as
leverage and you aren't thinking about
opting out i support it because there
are so many different ways the league
can squeeze players if there's something
that falls into a player's lap that lets
them squeeze back i say go for it but
setting aside the possibility that
someone would do it simply for leverage
i think it's appropriate when you're
considering the factors that trenavius
white is trying to balance being away
from family yeah his his
uh significant other not being able to
come to the games you know and you you
look at well what am i being paid this
year i'm being paid 1.8 million will uh
what if they offer me more well that may
change the analysis what if they offer
me the second contract that i've earned
by becoming an all-pro and remember all
pro more difficult than pro bowl
everybody makes the pro bowl except
chris everybody makes the pro no
did you ever make a pro bowl no nobody
no only only two corners are first team
all pros league wide you don't get to
opt out of the of the all pro it's just
a piece of paper so trudeau is white one
of the best two corners at least
according to 50 ap voters last year uh
that that's a big deal he's achieved a
lot in three nfl seasons and
uh if they would offer him that
long-term contract that he surely thinks
he deserves and he's happy with the
numbers yeah that would change his mind
chris it would be a factor it should be
a factor
on the fence about what to do yeah
that's right i mean it'll take the hurt
you know off off of the circumstances
certainly you know give you something a
little sweet in the pot uh and you know
one you know i think the thing that
jumps out to me from the clip and
everything i read and saw yesterday yeah
i don't like i'll echo something you
kind of said i don't think he's doing
this simply as a ploy to get more money
i think his reasoning and his concerns
are real like he said his old lady you
know his kids everything like that he's
not going to see them be around them
that's a real issue hey that's a support
system for a football player you know to
go home and whatever that dynamic is
maybe with your kids you know girlfriend
fiance wife whatever it is yeah it's a
big part some players that's part of
their football life and you know i think
that does probably hurt him and then he
looks at it also and then goes okay yeah
i'm pretty damn good like you just said
he's an all-pro he's one of the better
corners in football he's by far the best
corner on the buffalo bills team and has
leverage there because if there's a spot
on their roster that's a little weak it
is the corner position they don't have a
guy that can be they're a zone defense
and he's the only guy that can be
somewhat of a lockdown man-to-man type
corner and then the other aspect of this
mic that i think we just gotta talk to
because i think it's relevant here
is just okay yeah
you know pandemic okay really good
player deserves more money than he's
being paid
and then do you think he heard maybe in
the last few days that stefan diggs
contract got sweetened before training
camp and then that makes him think you
know those are things i just think about
and that's perfectly normal and and i
have no issue with that at all as far as
tridevious white's concerned but it just
you know kind of screams at you there
and we're going to pivot to that let me
just say this in the event that you
tuned in
after we played the sound from tredavius
white and before chris referred to
trenavius white's significant other as
old lady that's the quote that he he
used right
there's an awkward little donut hole
there yeah they just happened to turn us
on and chris is using a term from the
70s man like i haven't heard someone
referred to like that in decades i was
like right in the back when i heard
trenavius white say that it's great and
then that you know yeah i'm checking i'm
chickening out now too because i'm like
i don't know wait is it his fiance is he
married you know i need to look that up
as we're sitting here in a commercial
break or whatever it is so i just use
the same word that he is right which is
uh the old lady which is yeah you're
right you don't hear that it's old
school old school for sure his term his
term not our turn all right stefan diggs
speaking of terms tweaked contract on
tuesday
and it was the antonio brown type of
restructure this is what the steelers
did because the steelers have this hard
and fast rule they will never
redo a contract for a player who has
more than one year left they'll never
redo it for a quarterback who has more
than two years left so antonio brown
locked into a long-term deer in 2012
that he quickly outplayed
and he started to jostle and now we know
now that we know more about antonio
brown it's amazing that they managed to
keep a lid on it and to keep him from
exploding for as long as they did and it
explains why they deviated from their
practice but what they always did
instead of creating a new contract they
would take money from future years and
accelerate it into this year so they
weren't really giving him a new contract
but they were giving him more money now
and the reality was he would borrow
against the last year of the deal and by
then it won't matter because he gets a
new deal and that's exactly what
happened right that's what the bills
have done with stefan diggs who
before yesterday or technically tuesday
was the 13th highest paid receiver in
football with a deal that averaged 14.4
million per year in new money when he
signed it with the vikings he gets
traded he doesn't get a new contract
here we are two days before the opt-out
deadline his contract is tweaked with
3.3 million more this year
300 000 less next year but 7.7 million
dollars more in guaranteed money next
year and then a reduction of 2.88
million in salary for the last two years
of the deal 2022 2023 so they move some
money around they increase some
guarantee they give him more now
and it's funny chris because he met with
the media yesterday and he said he's not
going to opt out he's also not jostling
for a new contract right and then the
report comes out five minutes later he's
already gotten the new contract he's
never gotten the sweetener is it
technically a new contract
it's not it's not well it is but it
isn't yeah but here's the thing your
instincts are right i mean
and and i don't think there's anything
wrong with us saying
this may be what went on because they're
not going to come out and say it's what
went on it's in no one's interest not in
the bill's interest to look like they
caved it's not in staphon dig's interest
to create the impression that he used
the pandemic as leverage to get more
money this year but it very well may be
i mean this is a guy who said in july i
don't know about this right right right
i mean if you show up and you're like i
don't know about this and at the same
time the bills are aware he'd kind of
like to get this contract tweaked yeah
uh to have it all happen to have it all
get threaded through the needle two days
before the opt out deadline it invites
some speculation number one
that stefan diggs used that leverage to
get the contract tweaking number two
tredavious white is thinking hey it
worked for him right it should work for
me yeah no i you know yes and and both
players got leverage stefan diggs
probably more in this situation after
you make that kind of trade in the
offseason buffalo did with the minnesota
vikings and yes they want to keep him
there keep him happy i mean buffalo come
on they're
they're the window just open for them to
maybe start a super bowl run or be a
team that's you know in the super bowl
conversation for years to come here
they've set something up nice and diggs
is a big part of that plan and i think
he they looked at him like man we got
you we run this new england system you
fit so perfectly in it you can be julian
edelman yet we can line you up outside
and you can beat people for 80 yard
bombs like if you're sitting here
watching on tv like we saw in person you
know in the divisional playoff game
against the 49ers so he's a he has a
special skill set that way and i think
they know that and of course they wanted
him to fit their scheme which i think he
really will and yeah he had leverage
here plus you know he he voiced his
concerns like you said we we've heard he
has what did i say did i say something
silly
no no our b-roll package our b-roll
package was capped with stephon diggs
slow motion spinning a loogie through
the air like i just did as i said right
right just it's beaut it was very hard
it's beautiful very hard because we saw
it fly through the air yeah all right go
ahead and get some nfl films music
behind it
but
yeah i know i just think that you know
and then yeah we hear the concerns he
has about the pandemic and playing
football he just had a a brand new baby
so that was a real issue so i think he
probably voiced those concerns to his
agent or whatever else and they called
brandon bean okay dr lugi said something
funny now you said something funny and
pete demolitis pointed out to me yes a
brand new baby
not to be confused with the other kind
of baby yes yes okay that's a brand new
baby it is a brand new baby it's brand
new it is but yeah i think they probably
realize and they want to keep him happy
and he's in their plans for a while you
know they've been they invested a high
draft pick in josh allen they want to
make sure that takes off stefan diggs is
a big part of that so i get it and you
certainly can make the case that yeah
stefan diggs was certainly underpaid
there's guys that are making more money
than him at the position that i can sit
here and tell you that yeah i don't
think they're as good as he is so uh
good for the bills to smooth it over and
i'm happy we'll see stefan diggs playing
football this year but i do think that's
part of trenavius white i i think he
found out and i wouldn't i wouldn't be
shocked if he's just trying to use that
just as a little leverage and he's and
he's being very honest about a situation
i don't deny that either
well and and the thing is it's not going
to be quite so simple to just shift some
money around for trinavius white this is
second contract yeah for trinavius white
right they're not gonna say well you
know what we'll give you some of your 10
million that you're going to make in
your option year now no no this is
pay me now this is the time the window's
open patrick mahomes has gotten his deal
others who have gotten their three years
in have gotten their deals i want my
deal i deserve my deal and uh we'll see
what the deal is i think they got money
for buffalo though between between old
ladies and brand new babies we have
completely they got the money to do it
though in buffalo i mean am i right i
sit here and look at it and go they're
they're they're fifth in salary cap
right now in the nfl they certainly have
the change to throw it around i don't
know if they're trying to make any think
of any moves here but you're right i
know it's different times and you got to
balance a lot of hang on yeah
having cap space and having cash in a
pandemic are two very different things
yeah that may be part of it but we saw
the
la chargers dig very deep very deep and
blow us away with that joey bosa
contract that contract we had the
numbers over the weekend you're still
drooling over earlier in the week
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable that
he got what he got in this climate from
that team yeah and you know we brought
the subject up last week and i think it
was rodney harrison that pointed out
well they are the chargers i mean they
they tend to do they tend to do things
maybe they shouldn't do and in this case
maybe they shouldn't have given him all
that money now but they did and it
really is impressive but that's got to
be something trenavius white david's
looking at i mean you know your agent is
going to be looking at all the deals
that get that to get done all the
players who get rewarded and uh and and
there is an obvious and natural
leverage point that expires at 4 pm
eastern today the only thing is
if you go through that door right if you
play that card
that's a that's a tough card to unplay
you say i'm opting out you're gone for
the year so you hurt yourself but you
also dramatically hurt the team as you
said they don't have the services of
trudavius white for the entire season
right yeah they're getting back next
year but it's not going to help them
this year when the opening is there to
try to overtake the patriots in the
afc east all right uh now are there
others and and i don't like speculating
on this because for each guy it's an
intensely personal decision there was a
rumor last week that there was
potentially a group of players who were
going to announce their decision
together maybe they're saving it for
today i haven't heard
that same rumor with the same intensity
that i was hearing a week ago but you
heard it i heard it it was out there
yeah it hasn't happened yet we've got
until four o'clock eastern today for it
to happen and that would be something i
mean if you're going to do it if you
have any flair for the dramatic today's
the do it today to do it right before
the 4 p.m eastern deadline if there was
some some group of players with you know
high name recognition that would all opt
out at the same time that would put the
nfl on its ear yeah it definitely would
there there's i mean that would be a
blow to whatever team's got you know
players that decide to opt out here at
this last minute you know because as
you're sitting there right now
you know a lot of these coaches and
organizations they're going forward and
going okay here's the guys we got okay
looks good you know and yeah you lose a
major starter here you know just before
the opt-out deadline yeah that's gonna
change some things around all of a
sudden you're gonna have to look back
into the free agency you know pool and
go oh man who's out there who's
available at this position that we can
you know fill this void with uh it is
different from that year but i i haven't
heard that you know that rumor has died
down and listen i know you heard it i
heard it other nfl insiders heard it i
know coaches in the nfl that were
hearing it too
um and i don't know maybe it was the
stephon diggs and the chernavious whites
of the world who were all just kind of
like eh i'm not sure and they told their
agent and their agent you know told a
few people it's kind of just seeped out
through you know the the branches of the
nfl rumorville here but i have not heard
anything substantial about any names
that i could certainly throw out there
to say that oh i'm hearing this right
now or this guy's on the fence still
and the thing is just because trudavius
white was transparent about his position
doesn't mean that anyone else has been
you don't have to be and i think
tridevious white deliberately said what
he said yesterday he could have
sidestepped that question he could have
said nothing right we see plenty of
players and coaches not respond to
questions or give an answer that sends
people in a different direction he laid
it all bare and i think that's his last
move that's his final check to see
whether or not he can get the bills in
checkmate when it comes to pay him a new
contract i believe so that's something
to pay attention to today will it be
true davious white will he get a new
contract we'll find out uh but uh yeah
look i'm i'm ready for anything today
because this is it 4 p.m eastern speak
now forever hold your peace but remember
if you're not sure what to do and you
don't want to do the irrevocable opt out
the retirement option is a possibility
talk to your agent today right now text
him or her right now they're they're
working for you what would i owe if
anything if i choose to retire in
september after i go to a game or two
and i don't feel comfortable can i
retire then yes how much would i have to
pay back well that's the answer to the
question that i think will drive some of
these determinations and may keep some
guys from opting what do you think
though over under today over under today
like what do you think do you think it's
five i don't know because
all along well i know that's what i mean
i mean like i i think eight and a half
eight and a half that's where you're
gonna set it up i would go under i would
go under all the way i would think we've
seen the majority of the opt outs you
might have one or two guys today who go
okay i've been thinking about this this
is it i'm out of here but i would think
that everybody else has kind of wrapped
their head around all right i've made it
this far it looks pretty good
you know it's better than what i thought
that's the one thing we continue to hear
to where yeah i'm gonna say it's a low
number
when you consider the sheer number of
players in camps right now and the fact
that you know we all procrastinate the
nfl is a deadline driven business anyway
there could be guys who have had this
nagging sense
and like anything else whatever it is
something needs to be fixed at your
house something needs to be done with
your car something else that you you
know you put it off as long as you can
i'm eventually going to have to deal
with this i'm eventually going to have
to deal with this well today's the day
when they wake up they roll out of bed
and they say i have to deal with it
that's why i think
i'd go over eight and a half because i
think there may be some guys human
nature who have put this off as long as
they can they're going to face reality
today and they're going to make that
final and binding decision unless
they're confident they could retire
later that may drive the number down if
they yeah right to your agents and find
out what you would owe if you retire
later
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports